JUST GONNA REMIND EVERYBODY
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROTOCOLS. HI
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS. TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THESE
OF COURSE WILL BE CHANGING VERY
SOON AS WE- START TO REOPEN. TO
ALLOW REPUBLICANS SAYS WE WOULD
NEEDED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWING WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE OR IS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT. ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MORE
EXPOSURE FOR THE SENATE INDOOR.
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLICADA YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MOTHER TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU TO A
LINE NUMBER. THIS COULD BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WAIT IN A
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE CALL
YOUR LAN MY NUMBER. AND GIVE ME
A MINUTE TO READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO MEET ALL YOUR
DEVICES. IMAGE AINTAIN DECORUM
AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND JUST WANNA
REMIND FOLKS THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES IS WHAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO USE ONLINE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES. ALL RIGHT. I'M
GONNA CALL THE HEARING TO ORDER
WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM WATER MEMBERS ARE
OVER IN THE BUDGET. HEARING
THIS MORNING BUT I DO WANT TO
WELCOME OUR- BY MY GOOD FRIEND
AND OUR VICE CHAIR. STATE
SENATOR BATES WHO'S HERE. ARE
WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WITH THE BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND SO- WE'RE
GOING TO. WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED SO WHY DON'T WE DON
BECAUSE SENATOR STERN WAS GOING
TO PRESENT AT. THE AJ. YES
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT OKAY SO-
SINISTER IN IS GOING TO PRESENT
EASIER TO WHEN HE GETS HERE IN
LIEU OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AN ARRANGEMENT HAS
BEEN MADE. BUT I DO SEE A
COUPLE OF OUR AUTHORS HERE
LET'S START WITH CRISTINA
GARCIA WHO WILL PRESENT AJ ARE
FOR. AND THEN WE'LL GO FROM
THERE. YOU ARE VERY WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. IN K.
PRECIADO IT- HR FOUR CALLS FOR
THE UNITED STATES RATIFICATION
OF THE BASSEL AGREEMENT. OR
CRITICAL STEP IMPROPERLY
REGULATING THE INTERNATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE THE
PLASTIC DUMPING ON DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES. THE BEST A
CONVENTION RESOLUTION ON THE
CONTROLLER CAN SPONSOR
MOVEMENTS VASSAR'S WASTE AND
THEIR DISPOSAL. WAS SIGNED BUT
NEVER RATIFIED BY THE UNITED
STATES- WE ARE ONE OF THE ONLY
INDUSTRIAL COUNTRIES THAT HAS
NOT ADOPTED. BY THE BASSIL
AGREEMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TODAY. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE JORDAN WELL TO THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL. AND JIM. PUCKETT WITH
THE BATTLE ACTION NETWORK.
THANK YOU I'M HERE WITNESS MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE GET THE
VOLUME UP A LITTLE BIT ON THAT.
YEAH RIGHT. COULD BE BETTER YES
YES A LITTLE BIT BETTER THANK
YOU YOU MAY PROCEED. YES I'M
JIM POCKET EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BASEL ACTION NETWORK. A
GLOBAL NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WHOSE MISSION IT
CAN'T BE IN GLOBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
OBJECTIVES. BUT USING TOXIC
TRADE. WATCHDOG AND PROMOTE
UNITED NATIONS BOB WILL
CONVENTION. WHILE THE
CONVENTION THE WORLD'S FIRST ON
WEIGHT AND STANDS OF THE
LANDMARK FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THE TREATY HAS MAJOR
GLOBAL SUPPORT IS NOW RATIFIED
BY EIGHTY SEVEN PARTY COUNTRY.
BETWEEN THE COLORS FROM
NATIONAL SELF SUFFICIENCY IN
WEIGHT MANAGEMENT. IT HAS
ESTABLISHED A BAN ON THE EXPORT
OF HELP LOSE WEIGHT THROUGH
DEVELOPING COUNTRY AND FOR
OTHER WAYS SUCH AS MIXED AND
CONTAMINATED PLASTICS.
THOUSANDS OF REQUIRED PROCEDURE
OF NOTIFICATION AND CONSENT OF
THE IMPORTING COUNTRY PRIOR TO
EXPORT THIS REGIME ENSURES
TRANSPARENCY OF DRUGS ONE OF
THEM THE SHIPMENT WE'RE GOING
AND ASSURANCE THE BOOK WE- WILL
BE MANAGED. IN ENVIRONMENTS
FOUND MANNER. FIRST THE U. S.
IS NOT A- BY TREATED. WITH THE
DEVELOP COUNTRIES IT'S NOT IT
ONLY OF EIGHT COUNTRIES EARTH
IN TOTAL THAT HAVE. YEAH WHILE
MOST OF RUNNING. ARE THE WITH.
CAL ELSEWHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THE BET LITTLE UNIT BY THE
WORLD CHRIS TRAFFICKING IN
WRITTEN. I'M GOING TO EXPORTING
CONTENT PLASTICS COUNTRIES DO
NOT CONSERVE TO THEIR IN. MANY
OF THE CONSUMER CURRENTLY
RECEIVING ETHNIC STEM CLASS.
I'M ABLE ADEQUATELY RECYCLABLE
WASTE IN LARGE FRACTURE OF IT
PERCENT THANK AND BURNED. HE
LONG WE AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
USING COUNTRIES THAT. SOMETHING
FILE THEIR LAWS BECAUSE
INSURANCE HARD. AT THE SAME
TIME WE DO OUR NO OF NO FAVORS
BY FAILING TO REDUCE OUR WASTE
UPSTREAM I'VE CALLED FOR BY
PUBLIC THAT SHOULD. IT'S BEEN
ALL TO ME YOU SIMPLY EXPERT
FROM. THIS MONTH FINALLY. THE
PRIME THE BASEL CONVENTION BE A
STEP NOW FOR GLOBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL. BUT YOU ALSO
WANT BETTER MATURE AND WE
MANAGED TO MINIMIZE WINSTON. I
URGE YOUR I HAD BOTH. FOR THE
DEMONSTRATION TO RATIFY THE BAR
BRIDGE BY PAST OF HR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND MAY PARKER
I'M NEXT WE HAVE FIVE WELLS
FROM THE NASH STORAGE ACTION K.
CAN'T HEAR IS THEIR WAY TO MAKE
SURE THE BALL IS. ADEQUATE.
BETTER YET MUCH BETTER. I THINK
YOU CAN NUMBER AND TIME AGAIN
I'M BURDEN OF THE DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL. WELL AND EXACT
HEIDI STANDPOINT FOR THE DAY
WHITE COMMISSION RECYCLE
MARKETS GROUP THAT. UNANIMOUSLY
ADOPTED A HOCKEY RECOMMENDATION
THE SEVENTEEN ZERO. REQUESTING
CAL ENCOURAGE FEDERAL ACTIONS
LED BY THE BOTH BUT CHEN. RIGHT
AIRPORT. WAY AND- COURT. YEAH
FOR CALLING YOU BITE INTO.
QUICKLY RATIFIED PUBLIC
AGREEMENT WHICH IS A CRITICAL
STEP OF. RAY THE INTERNET
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE I IN
HAZARDOUS WE- ARE. THAT
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO PROPERLY MANAGE
THE MATERIAL. OUR THAT EVER ON
JUNE FIRST TWENTY TRY OF BECOME.
AGREEMENT WENT EFFECT THAT
TREAT CLASS EQUATE. A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN INTRODUCTORY
PARTNER. NEEDS RAW REQUIRE THAT
CLASSIC WE- WHICH IS NOT SORTED
AND CLEAN KEEPING UP. AND
WITHOUT. CONTAMINATION THE ONLY
BE ALLOW FOR X. TO OTHER BALK
MCCARTY WHEN THERE ARE. I'M
WITHOUT MANAGEMENT AND ONLY IF
YOU'RE- PARTY FIRST BY THE A
COUNTRY DETECTING THAT. THE
MOST IMPORTANT FOR CAL IS THAT
THE A HUNDRED SEVEN LONG THE
PARTY NOT BE ABLE TO LEGALLY
RECEIVE. U. S. AT ALL IF YOU'RE
NOT A PARTY TO THE COULD.
CONGRESS FAILURE TO READ THE
COULD ON US. I THINK AT THE
INDIVIDUAL. EITHER WAY. THE
PROBLEM IS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATE
POLLUTION OUT OF THE BOX
CONVENTION INCLUDING INDEX WAIT
EVENING YOU MORE URGENT
RATIFIED THE TREATY TO PUT
PUBLIC ENEMY BY HEALTH AROUND
THE WORLD WE URGE OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY I LET'S GO TO. THE POLICE
MY BEST RIVERSIDE. LET'S GO
LET'S GO TO OUR- PUBLIC COMMENT.
I DON'T SEE HERE IN PER TO. I
DON'T SEE IN TWENTY FORTY TO
COMMENT- WE CAN THEN TURN TO.
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR'S
pANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES WHO'S
LIKE WHO WOULD LIKE TO. COMMENT
ON AJ ARE FOR. THANK YOU COULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT ON A DAY
ARE FOR THIS PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD MISTRUST
THE ONE OVER BUT THE ZERO. WE
HAVE A FEW LINES IN Q. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE EIGHTEEN ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS PERSONAL
JET OFF ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOU'RE SHOULD CANCEL
AND STOP WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I'M I'M SO SORRY BUT ONE
SECOND MODERATOR LET ME JUST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM UICKLY-
BECAUSE I NOTICED A QUORUM IS
TENTATIVELY PRESENT. FIVE
SURGERY PLEASE AB CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN HERE
ALLEN HERE BATES BATES HERE
DALLYING. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HERE SKINNER STERN HERE STERN
HERE WHAT KASKY. OKAY WE HAVE
IT WE JUST BARELY HAVE A QUORUM
APPRECIATE THAT LET'S GO TO THE
RETURN OF THE PHONE LINE FOR
COMMENTS ON AJ R. FOR WHERE
WE'RE HEARING FROM- SUPPORTERS
OF AG ARE FOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CEMEX RAIL LINE FIFTEEN ONE
FIVE. SH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WITH YOU
JENNIFER HEARING EXPRESSING
SUPPORT FOR A DOWNPOUR ON
BEHALF OF OCEANIC. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE. SIXTEEN ONE SIX.
THIS IS YOUR LANE WOULD BE A
PAYMENT CREATIVE INNOVATION
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABILITY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AJ ARE FOR- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL REALLY
HELP US START BEING MORE
INDEPENDENT AND REDUCE THE HARM
THAT OUR AERICAN CONSUMERISM
IS BRINGING UP ANOTHER COUNTRY
AND ALSO THE PRIEST ON THE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXRAD LINE. TWENTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BASS WITH THE PAY AND
MAKE KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND SUPPORT
OF A J. R. FOUR THANK YOU. NOW
LINE. SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN. THIS
IS ALSO CALLED TO THE CORRECT.
YOUR RECYCLING INSTITUTE IN THE
COURT H. A. R. FOR. PINE.
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
BRITAIN OKAY I'LL BE HAPPY TO
RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND ONE NEXRAD LINE TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING GO ON BEHALF
OF THE STORE AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NO FOR THE LINES IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S
NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY RICH
ROBINSON I CERTAINLY I KNOW ONE
IS OF COURSE THE COMMITTEE
ASKED OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE
ONE HERE IN PERSON OR IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY HI IS AYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR WHO
IS CALLED IN TO EXPRESS
CONCERNS OR OPPOSITION. TO EGF
ARE FOR. IF YOU'D LIKE TO STATE
A POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO HR
FOR THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION ASK
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS- ABOUT ITEM
TO A CHAIR FOR FROM OR FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BOB I WANTED
BUT I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR- RAISING- A SPOTLIGHT ON
THIS IMMENSELY IMPORTANT
CONVENTION- YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE
I THINK EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
HOW COMMITTED THIS COMMITTEE IS
SAID TO. THIS WHOLE FIVE
CHALLENGE ASSOCIATE WITH
PLASTIC WASTE AND THE BASEL
CONVENTION IS- IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT INTERNATIONAL EFFORT
IN THIS AREA AND I WOULD VERY
MUCH SHARE YOUR- HOPE THAT WE
RATIFY THE CONVENTION AND I'M
AND- I'M PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
THIS. RESOLUTION SO I WANNA
WHEN I THINK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING FORWARD AND
LET'S HOPE TO LET'S HOPE WE CAN
SPUR SOME ACTION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. I SEE THAT IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GONZALEZ. AND
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR THOUGHTS AS ALWAYS BUT NOT A
MAESTER. I'M JUST GONNA STAND
FOR A MOMENT I'M STILL TRYING
TO HEAR FROM MY MAJOR RECYCLER
IN IN MY DISTRICT IT SEEMS GOOD
BUT I THINK I'LL I'M JUST GOING
TO LAY OFF FOR THIS VOTE AT THE
MOMENT. BUT I THINK IT SOUNDS
LIKE A GOOD IDEA BECAUSE WE ALL
WANT. PLASTIC REDUCTION. THANK
YOU FOR THE SENATE. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE SAID THAT THEY
GIVE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP- AND
JANEANE YOUR CALL TO SHIP ON
THIS BILL. WE ARE ONE AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES ONE OF
A HANDFUL OF COUNTRIES YOU HAVE
AND RATIFIED THIS AND SO.
COMMITTED TO THE- ARAMBULA
COMMUNITY TO WORK ON THIS
TOGETHER INTO SEARCHING
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO TAKE ACTION
IMMEDIATELY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SO PLEASE OTHER OF. I A
NUMBER TO THEY ARE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI ALLEN I BATES. BATES
NOT VOTING DOLLY GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI SKINNER STERN Y.
CASKEY. I WOULD HOLD A ROLL
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ON
WHAT LOT OF FOLKS OVER BUDGET
COMMITTEE THANK YOU- BUT THANK
YOU. ALRIGHT LET'S NOW GO I SEE
A SOMBER QUIRK HAS BEEN.
USUALLY WAITING SINCE LONG-BEFORE THE START OF THE MEETING
WE WELCOME YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I TO PRESENT A. B. THREE ZERO
FOUR THIS IS A BILL RELATING TO.
I WATER RELEASES- AND GROUND
WATER CONTAMINATION ECSTATIC
CONTAMINATED SITES AND- SO WE
TURN TO YOU THIS ITEM FOR YOUR
PACKETS MEMBERS I AB THREE ZERO
FOUR. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR AND CENTER GONZALEZ-
AB THREE OH FOUR WILL PROVIDE
STATE OVERSIGHT AND SET
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS OVERSEEING THE CLEANUP
OF HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES ARE
CURRENTLY THOUSANDS OF
CONTAMINATED SITES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT REQUIRE
REMEDIATION THE SITES CAN BE
COMPLEX AND CAN IMPACT NEARBY
COMMUNITIES AND THE ENVIRONMENT
THEY'RE NOT CLEAN CLEANED UP
CORRECTLY. A STATE WATER BOARD
DTS SHE HAVE EXTENSIVE
PROCEDURES THE MUSTARD HERE TO
WHEN CONDUCTING OR OVERSEEING
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CLEANUP BUT
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS DO
NOT HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
SAME STANDARDS THE INTENT OF
THREE OH FORCED HELP ENSURE
THAT LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS WHO
OVERSEE THE CLEANUP OF
CONTAMINATED SITES OF THE
NECESSARY EXPERTISE KNOWLEDGE
AND RESOURCES TO CARRY OUT
REMEDIATION RESPONSIBILITIES IN
A MATTER THAT IS A PROTECTIVE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. LAST YEAR I
INTRODUCED A SIMILAR BILL AB.
TWO THREE THREE THREE THREE OUR
SYSTEM WE'VE WORKED
PRODUCTIVELY WITH A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND STRENGTHEN
OUR BILL AB THREE OH FOUR
REFLECTS THOSE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS AB THREE OH FOUR
HAS NO OPPOSITION OR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO NUMBER HI. SO
LET'S ADD DENTAL TEAM HERE OR
IN TWENTY FORTY LIKE TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY FOLKS
ON THE PHONE LINES TO LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB.
THREE OH FOUR. TO STATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI THRILLED FOR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN TO SUPPORT A BE THRILLED
FOR ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. COLONEL LINES IN
Q. OKAY. I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANYONE TO TESTIFY AND WE
OPPOSITION OR IN PERSON- IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES ONE
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT AB THREE OR FOUR.
SURE OPPOSITION TO AB THRILL
FOR ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. OKAY
ARE WILL BRING THE ITEM TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ANY QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
ON THE TWENTY MEMBERS MISS OUT
OF MY CHAIR I JUST A QUESTION
QUICK QUESTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. QUICK IF THERE ANY
ARMED OPPOSITION FROM THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS I UNDERSTAND
THEY GENERALLY ARE IN SUPPORT
OR NEUTRAL IS FAT- IS THEIR
SEARCH IT THERE EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR NEUTRAL SO LAST YEAR
I HAD THE BILL THAT THEY DIDN'T
LIKE SO WE ASK THAT BE HELD.
AND THIS BILL NOW IS DIFFERENT
AND FOR THAT REASON THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ARE. EITHER NEUTRAL OR
IN SUPPORT. OF CONTROL WITH IT
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE MIGHT BE A
STANDARD THAT BY WHICH THEY
WILL BE OUR- EVALUATED IN TERMS
OF. THEIR QUALIFICATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE KIND OF
REMEDIATION AND CLEAN UPS ARE
YOU KNOW TO THE TO THE LEVEL
THAT THAT IS NEEDED. THAT SEEMS
TO BE MAYBE WHAT THE PROBLEM
WAS THAT WITH WELL SO LAST YEAR
WE ASK THAT THEY TAKE CERTAIN
TRAINING. THIS YEAR WE ONLY ASK
THEM TO TELL. THE WATER BOARD
WHAT THEIR- CAPABILITIES ARE.
AND SO THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT-
TYPE THE BILL AND THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE THEY'VE CHANGED THEIR
POSITION WELL THAT IS WHY THEY
CHANGED THEIR POSITION SIMPLY
HAVE TO TELL THE WATER BOARD
YES WE HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO DO
THIS WAR NO WE DON'T WOULD LIKE
SOME HELP. GREAT THANK YOU MMHM.
CRYPT AND YOUR QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS CERTAINLY OKAY SO-
I'LL CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING
IT- IT'S REMOVED IF YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SUMMER ARE ASKED FOR YOUR
VOTE. OKAY ALL RIGHT I CAN
TOTALLY IS COLORADO. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB THREE OR FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN HI ALAN I
BATES. BATES AYE DALY GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI SKINNER STERN Y.
CASKEY. OKAY I WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
THAT WE HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE OVER
BUDGET COMMITTEE PUT THEM.
PRITCHETT PROCEDURE
PRESENTATION OKAY ALL RIGHT.
THIRTY WELL YOU ACTION THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT OKAY SO IT'S THAT
EASY A TIME AS YOU LIKE TO TELL
US MORE ABOUT IT PROCESS NO
IT'S JUST FINE OKAY. THAT'S
RIGHT AS A- ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
NEXT TO. OUR NEXT PRESENTER AT
THIS AB THIRTY NINE AT CHAO'S.
AND WE- WE NOW GO TO YOU I'M
GONNA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IRWIN AND CENTERS. AB THIRTY
NINE WOULD CODIFY AND
RECOGNIZED THE CALIFORNIA CHINA
CLIMATE INSTITUTE TO ACCELERATE
CLIMATE ACTION THROUGH
COOPERATIVE EFFORTS AND
EXCHANGES BETWEEN TWO OF THE
WORLD'S LARGEST ECONOMIC POWERS
AND MAJOR EMITTERS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES MAINLY
CALIFORNIA AND CHINA THERE ARE
MANY SERIOUS THREATS WE FACE
STEP ARE CONSTRAINED BY
NATIONAL BORDERS AND AFFECT
EVERYONE AROUND THE WORLD. THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MADE THAT CLEARTHE CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS IS NO DIFFERENT
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA'S-
PROXIMITY TO CHINA IT BENEFITS
OUR STATE GREATLY IF CHINA IS
ABLE TO REDUCE ITS GHG
EMISSIONS CHINA CURRENTLY EMITS
28% OF THE WORLD'S CARBON
DIOXIDE. MEANWHILE WE HAVE OUR
OWN POLLUTION CHALLENGES IN
CALIFORNIA ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION THE
LOS ANGELES AREA IS THE
SMOGGIEST METRO AREA IN THE
COUNTRY FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
TIME IN THE LAST TWENTY TWO
YEARS NINE OF THE TEN SMOGGIEST
COUNTIES IN THE COUNTRY ARE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH SAN BERNARDINO
AND RIVERSIDE AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BEING THE FIRST. SECOND
AND THIRD WORST IN THE NATION
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND REDUCE EMISSIONS WE MUST
HAVE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS AROUND
THE WORLD. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN FORMER GOVERNOR EDMUND
G. BROWN JUNIOR HELPED LAUNCH
THE CALIFORNIA CHINA INSTITUTE
TO PROMOTE CLIMATE ACTION
THROUGH JOINT RESEARCH TRAINING
AND DIALOGUE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND CHINA. THE INSTITUTE IS
PARTNERING WITH LEADING
ACADEMIC AND GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES IN CHINA AND PROVIDING
A PLATFORM TO BUILD THESE
URGENTLY NEEDED PARTNERSHIPS
THE INSTITUTE ADVANCES JOINT
POLICY RESEARCH ON MAJOR
CLIMATE ISSUES INCLUDING LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES CARBON
PRICING CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE. SUSTAINABLE LAND
USE AND CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE AND LONG TERM CLIMATE
GOAL SETTING AND POLICY
ENFORCEMENT. BY PASSING AB
THIRTY NINE AND FORMALLY
AUTHORIZING THE INSTITUTE IN
STATE LAW THE LEGISLATURE
CONSENT A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE WAY TO REVERSE CLIMATE
CHANGE BY ADVANCING JOIN
CLIMATE RESEARCH. WITH
COOPERATION THROUGH THE
INSTITUTE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TODAY FIRST OF ALL I
HAVE FORMER GOVERNOR EDMUND G.
BROWN JUNIOR AND SECOND HI
HOUSE NIKITA KHARADI WITH A
NASH- NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I WOULD THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT OUR- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S GO TO YOUR
WITNESSES. GOVERNOR IT'S GREAT
TO HEAR FROM YOU. WELL GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY OF THE VERY BRIEF-%
THIS IS A CHANCE FOR THE STATE.
TO LEGISLATIVE ENACTMENT- TO
JOIN WITH US AT THE INSTITUTE
AT UC- TO DO SOMETHING SERIOUS
ABOUT IT- CLIMATE CHANGE GLOBAL
WARMING THIS IS AN INCIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA- DURING THE CLIMB
INTO. AIMS TO ENGAGE IN AND
ENGAGE IN WE HAVE SEVERAL PEERS
HE'S WORKING WITH US IN
RESEARCH ON. CARBON NEUTRALITY
ON BUILDING REGULATIONS- CARBON
PRICING- USING WORKING LANDS-
TO THE QUESTION CARBON THIS IS
ALL PART OF AN EFFORT TO GET
OUR HANDS AROUND- THE TERRIBLE
THE THREAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE
SAW THE MEANING OF THE. G.
SEVEN. BRITAIN AND COULDN'T
EVEN AGREE YOU ON ONE GOING TO
BE COAL BUT WE'RE A LONG WAY
FROM WHAT WE NEED TO DO. THIS
IS AN INSTITUTE THAT EXPLICITLY
WORKS IN CALIFORNIA AND WORKS
WITH CHINESE PROVINCES THERE
ARE A LOT OF ISSUES ABOUT CHOI
A LOT OF ISSUES- AND PEOPLE ARE
VERY CONCERNED AND RIGHTLY SO
BUT- CHINA IS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO GLOBAL WARMING
BUT HE MUST IT WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL REDUCE. THEIR
EMISSIONS WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEM TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT IN
ALL THE OTHER SIDE ISSUES ARE
HOWEVER IMPORTANT YOU SEE THAT
MANY OF THEM ARE VERY IMPORTANT
NEVER THE LESS CLIMATE IS GOING
TO MAKE ALL OF THEM MUCH WORSE
WHAT THE CLIMATE DID DID DID
DID- DETERIORATING SO WE'VE GOT
TO GET OUT AND WE'RE A SMALL
PIECE. BUT AN IMPORTANT PIECE
WITH SOME OF THE BEST MINDS IN
THE WORLD WORKING WITH THIS SO
ASK YOU TO GIVE YOUR VOTER
CONFIDENCE AND CODIFY INTO LAW-
THE EXPRESSION THAT YOU ARE
JOINING WITH US IN THE
CALIFORNIA. CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU GOVERNOR.
ZURCHER YOU'RE WINNING IN HI
LET'S NOT GO TO ANY KICKER FROM
ENERGIES. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND GOOD MORNING TO GOVERNOR
BROWN ALWAYS INSPIRING TO HEAR
FROM YOU THIS IS NIKITA CRAPPIE
BUT THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND ENERGY
PEOPLE USED TO SUPPORT AB
THIRTY NINE TODAY WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE REGIONS OF THE
UC. WITHOUT WHICH THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA CLIMATE
INSTITUTE TO THIRD OF THE THINK
TANK WITH THE PURPOSE OF
ADVANCING CLIMATE POLICY AS ONE
OF THE FIRST INTERNATIONAL
NONPROFIT TO LAUNCH A CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAM IN CHINA I DON'T
EVEN SUPPORTING CHINA'S ANIMAL
DEVELOPMENT BY PROVIDING
TECHNICAL AND LEGAL EXPERTISE
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS. OF
THE NINETEEN NINETY THREE AND
COLLABORATING WITH A WIDE RANGE
OF CHINESE AND INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS POLITIC CHANGES AND
LEARNING DEVELOP INNOVATIVE
QUALITY. TOOLS TRAIN TRAIN.
LEGAL PROFESSION AND BY ADDED.
AND IN SEVEN BETTER. AND ENERGY
EFFICIENT. TRANSITIONAL CLEANER.
POLLUTION CONTROL. WHY CON. AND
LOW CARBON ORGANIZATION. FOR
EXAMPLE WE WORKED WITH CHINESE
COURTS TO BEGIN TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS USING MANY OF THE
LESSONS REQUIRED AT THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH.
MUCH LIKE ENERGY VIEWS WORK IN
CHINA THE CALIFORNIA TRYING TO
CLAIM AGAINST YOU MISSION THE
PREDICATED ON THE RECOGNITION.
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES
ARE NOT CONFINED BY GEOGRAPHIC
BORDERS. WITH A GREAT VALUE AND
INSTEAD FOCUS ON JOINT RESEARCH
TRAINING DIALOGUE
COLLABORATION. AND EXPLORATION
OF URGENTLY NEEDED CLIMATE
CONDITIONS AT ALL LEVELS. FOR
THESE REASONS WERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY NINE TODAY AND
THINK IF I REMEMBER CHILDHOOD.
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE PROJECT
UNITY TO. OKAY LET'S GO. TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE IN PERSON OR IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- LET'S NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR PEOPLE
WHO'D LIKE TO WIN IN SUPPORT.
OF AB. THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
TO SHARE SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE MIN ZERO
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE BOTTOM LINE.
TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS JENNIE
GOW ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. BY
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ON HERE
IN PERSON BUT IT DOESN'T ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR DUPLICATE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT AGAIN THE STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. USING YOUR
PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. OKAY WHAT'S BRING
THE BOTTOM BACK TO THE MEMBERS
FOR DISCUSSION NOW WILL GO TO
U. S. SENATE DOLLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IS SO I HAVE A
QUESTIONS- THE AUTHOR. IN IN
CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME EXAMPLES
OF WHEN CHINA'S EVER AGAIN- I
GUESTS BUT WITH THOSE WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR STATE THAT THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY. LISTEN TO WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN AND THROUGH THE
PARIS ACCORD OR ANY OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ACTUALLY- YOU
KNOW DONE WHAT THEY SAID THEY
WERE GONNA DO AND IN MY OPINION-
YEAH THEY THEY TALK A GOOD GAME
BUT- THE PIRATE OUR INFORMATION
THEY- POLLUTE LIKE CRAZY AS WE
LOOK. REGULATE CALIFORNIANS AND
AMERICANS AND IT NATIONALLY
THEY TAKE OUR JOBS AND THEY
POLLUTE OUR AIR SO WHAT MAKES
YOU THINK THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY. ABIDE BY SOME SORT OF
THE BINDING I GUESS I'LL
BINDING IS A SUCH A DIFFERENT
KIND OF FIGURE OUT WHY DO WHY
DO WE NEED THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER ICE I THINK
THIS IS- NOT A BINDING.
AGREEMENT AND ANY ANY FORM IT
IS A- IT IS A PARTNERSHIP.
BUILT BETWEEN THE TWO ENTITIES
AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE A THINK
TANK. KIND OF A SET UP. AND
IT'S DUE TO YOUR QUESTION I
THINK LAW. YOU MAY RECALL THAT-
EARLIER IN A POLL ON. HOW
CLIMATE ENVOY- JOHN KERRY HAD A
MEETING WITH ONE OF THE HIGHER
UPS IN CHINA I. DON'T REMEMBER
THE NAME OF THE GENTLEMAN. WHO
JOINTLY ISSUED A STATEMENT TO.
COLLABORATE ON THE ISSUE OF
CLIMATE. AND THIS IS PRETTY
MUCH IN LINE WITH WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING-
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
IDENTIFYING ISSUES THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH CHINA ON. A WHEN IT
COMES TO CLIMATE- CHINA HAS TO
BE PART OF THE EQUATION AS I
STATED EARLIER- DAY CURRENTLY
IN MAY 28% OF THE WORLD'S
CARBON DIOXIDE AND THAT'S THE
KIND OF. A STEP THAT WE BREATHE
IN EVERY DAY. SO THE SOONER
THAT WE COULD GET CHINA TO DROP
THAT NUMBER DOWN FROM TWENTY
PERCENT. THE SOONER WE CAN
BREATHE CLEANER AIR. SO TO DATA
THE INTENT UP BECAUSE- WE NEED.
TO WORK WITH THEM SO THAT THEY
COULD. HI SENSUALLY YOU'LL GET
THEIR NUMBER DOWN AND DATE THEY
HAVE A VESTED INTEREST IN DOING
THIS AS WELL. BUT YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
IS LOCATED SO CLOSE TO. TO
CHINA I THINK WE BEAR THE BRUNT
AND I THINK YOU KNOW COMPARED
TO OTHER STATES SO WE HAVE A E.
NO EVEN A STRONGER INTEREST. IT
GETTING THEIR NUMBER DOWN.
RIGHT AS WELL AS OUR NUMBER SO.
IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
BOTH PARTIES TO. CONTINUE THIS
KIND OF COLLABORATION I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT ARE YOU KNOW.
AT THE HAS THE GOVERNOR SAID
CHINA MAY HAVE ISSUES AND
POLICIES THAT WE DON'T ALL
AGREE WITH. BUT BUT YET THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE SHOULDN'T.
FOCUS AND ALL IDENTIFY ISSUES
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH HIM ON
AND THE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THEM. AND
TOP. CIVIL BOB SO WE NEED TO
KEEP DOING THOSE OF BECAUSE- IN
A WEEK YEAH THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR A WHILE AS FAR AS
CALIFORNIA'S CONCERN. SO THIS
IS IT YOU KNOW THE BILL
CENTENAS TO. HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THE WORK THAT THE IS TO HAS
BEEN DOING NUMBER ONE. AND
NUMBER TWO TO DEMONSTRATE THE
FACT THAT WE SHOULD BILL
PUNISHES WITH PEOPLE ACROSS YOU
KNOW. ACROSS THE PACIFIC OCEAN
AND YOU KNOW- THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD SO THAT IS THE ONLY WAY
WE COULD CONTINUE TO YOU KNOW.
TO GET THAT NUMBER DOWN I MEAN
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. THEY HAVE TO BE
PART OF THE EQUATION. SO I
WOULD. I AGREE THE FAT THAT
THEY ARE BLUE. I NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT AND WE'RE BREED IT WE WILL
EXPLORE MOST OF OUR MANY JOBS
IN AMERICA IN CALIFORNIA TO
THEM AS THEY CONTINUE TO
POLLUTE IT SO. MY POINT IS.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO DO
WITH THESE OTHER GUYS A
COMMUNIST COUNTRY THAT SLAVES
THERE. THERE'S NOT LIKE WE'RE
TALKING TO CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THESE THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO- DON'T HAVE HUMAN
RIGHTS WE HAVE HERE. AND THEY
THEY HAVE NOT IT DEMONSTRATED.
IN ANY EVENT THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
COMPLY WITH ANYTHING THEY TALK
THEY'LL SHOW UP THE TABLE BUT
WHEN THEY GO HOME. THEY DON'T
DO ANYTHING THEY'RE THEY'RE
POLLUTING OUR AIR. THEIR HUMAN
RIGHTS THERE THERE THERE'S
STUFF THEY DO TO PEOPLE IS.
ATROCIOUS AND SO I DON'T SEE
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO. USE
TALK A GOOD GAME HERE BUT NOT
BUT IT DOESN'T END UP WITH THE
OUTCOME WE WANT. AND WE'RE JUST
PROMOTING THEM TO CONTINUE TO
GROW AND CONTROL OUR COUNTY
AYE. I'M REBUILDING AN ENGINE
IN A TRACTOR RIGHT NOW AND I
WAITED. THREE WEEKS FOR PARTS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY. IN
CHINA. DOMINO SHOULDN'T WE IF
CHINA WANTS TO TAKE AMERICA
DOWN ALL YOU GOTTA DO STOP
MAKING BEARINGS AND WE'RE OUT
WE'RE DONE BECAUSE WE DON'T
MANUFACTURE MERE. AND SO THESE
PEOPLE ARE OUR FRIENDS. SO FOR
THE FOR THAT AND MANY REASONS I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS THIS IS
BINDING US. I WITH SENATOR
ROBERT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT STRENGTHENING
THEIR ECONOMY IT'S ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT RECOGNIZING THAT THERE'S
A GLOBAL CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
AND REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE THINK
ABOUT THE REGIME. IN THE CCP
WHICH AND I'M AND I SHARE A LOT
OF YOUR CONCERNS TO BE HONEST-
BUT WE WORKED WITH WITH
COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE WORLD
THAT HAVE ENGAGING. IN
PRACTICES THAT WE DON'T APPROVE
OF WHICH WE DON'T APPROVE- THE
WE WORK WITH THEM BECAUSE WE
SHARE MUTUAL INTERESTS ON A
PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE. HI THIS IS NOT
ABOUT TRYING TO STRENGTHEN THE
CHINESE ECONOMY HERE I HELP
THEM IN ANY WAY BEYOND OUR
MUTUALLY SHARED INTEREST IN
TRYING TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND SO ON YEAH BYE HI I JUST OF
MY MAKE AYE AYE AYE I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT YOU
SAID I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT FOR THE FOLKS ARE
WATCHING. THERE'S CLARITY AS TO
WHAT'S BEING. PROPOSED HERE
WITH THIS. BUT THIS BILL WILL
FOR THE RECORD MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I'LL SAY THIS. WE'RE THE ONLY
ONES. MAINLY CALIFORNIA EVEN
THE UNITED STATES THE COMPLY
WITH ALL THE STUFF IS
HAPPENING. AND WHAT IS IT DOING
TO OUR ECONOMY IS DRIVING UP
THE COST OF FUEL IS DRIVING UP
THE COST OF ELECTRICITY.
DRIVING UP THE COST OF LIVING
ALL THOSE INJURED. AND WE
CANNOT GET THE- PARTS WE CAN'T
GET THE PIECES A STEP THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE AMERICA RUN. AND
SO I WILL JUST TELL YOU WERE
THE ONLY ONES COMPLY NOBODY
ELSE COMPLAINING ALL OF OURS
JUST THIS IS NOT GONNA. BUT
THAT'S WHY I'M TRYING TO GET
HOUSE AGAIN HOW YOU GONNA FORCE
THEM. TO DO SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE DOING. SACRIFICES HAPPEN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE FOR
ABSOLUTE NOT IF WE DON'T GET
OTHER COUNTRIES AND MAC
POWERFUL ECONOMIES LIKE CHINA
ON BOARD. THE EFFORT AND THANK
YOU FOR MAKING MY POINT THEY
DON'T EVER DO IT THOUGH. YOU'RE
RIGHT WAS ARCHES ARE TWELVE.
INCH EACH AND I ASK FOR
EXAMPLES OF WHERE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DOING IT. AND I DIDN'T
HEAR ANY- THERE WERE- AT THE
TABLE. I MEAN I OBVIOUSLY WANT
TO. YOU KNOW JUST I. FIVE DAYS
YOU WANT TO BE. OF YOUR
QUESTIONS MEAN IT'S YOU KNOW
THAT THEIR- THERE'S A- OF.
RIGHT NOW IN CHINA ON TRYING TO
TRANSITION THEIR ECONOMY
TOWARD. CLEANER FUELS. AND
THEY'VE GOT A MASSIVE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE
THEY- THEY RECOGNIZE MORE THAN
ANYONE THAT THERE IS A HUGE.
HUGE PROBLEM ON THEIR HANDS OF
THE GUARDS TO POLLUTION-
THERE'S A WHOLE PIECE AND- NOT
TOO LONG AGO. IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES ABOUT HOW IT'S CHILD
ABUSE TO RAISE YOUR KID IN
BEIJING BECAUSE OUTSIDE THE
AREAS- SO. THAT THEIR DAY BUT
THERE'SA THERE'S A THERE'S A
STRONG RECOGNITION OF THEIR
NEED TO GET WITH THE PROGRAM-
AND- YOU KNOW I JUST THINK.
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT I WILL I
YOU KNOW I'D. WAY THAT WE WOULD
LIKE BUT- IN THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS A POWERFUL. SOVEREIGN
NATION- AND OUR OUR PLAN IT
REALLY DEPENDS ON OUR ABILITY.
TO WORK WITH THEM. TO HAVE TO
PUSH THEM. TOWARD MORE
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES AND
THAT'S REALLY ALL THIS IS DOING
I COULD OFFER UP A WAY TO DO
THAT. LET'S MANUFACTURE CLEAN
GOOD JOBS HERE IN AMERICANS BE
SELF SUSTAINING. SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO. HAVE THEM USE THEIR
SLAVES. TO PROP DID GET THE
PRODUCTS WE NEED AND ALSO PUT
HER AT THE SAME TIME. YEP YEP
WELL I DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH YOU AND I LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON GETTING GOOD GREEN
JOBS HERE IN. CALIFORNIA UNITED
STATES. SENATE GONZALEZ. S.
THANK YOU AND- I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I'M OF THAT THAT-
IDEA THAT THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING FORWARD I
MEAN. THIS IS ALREADY HAPPENING
AS YOU MENTIONED HIGHLIGHTING
COLLABORATION JOINT POLICY
RESEARCH PROVIDING TRAINING
CALIFORNIANS. I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF- VISITING THE
CHINESE ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
WHEN I WAS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH REPRESENTING THE PORT.
HAVING SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY. AND STILL FINDING
DIALOGUE REALLY REALLY FRUITFUL
AMONG- CHINESE ACADEMICS FOR ME
AS A CALIFORNIAN WAS HELPFUL SO
I THINK THAT LEVELING THIS UP
EVEN MORE SO IN THAT RESPECT IS
SOMETHING THAT I LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING AND- AS THE NEW
CHAIR TRANSPORTATION ALSO-
HAPPY THAT TO CONTINUE. TO WORK
WITH YOU AND- WOULD LOVE TO YOU
KNOW. A AND SURE THAT WE MOVE
THIS THROUGH AND- AND HELP IN
ANY WAY THAT I CAN TO PROMOTE
TO PUT. YOU KNOW DIPLOMACY IN A
DIFFERENT WAY BUT ALSO- CREATE
DIFFERENT RELATIONSHIPS WITH
INTEGRITY WHICH I KNOW IS THE
INTENT OF THIS THANK YOU. BAKER
CENTER- ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU
IF YOU IF WE MAY I IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR BROWN. I WOULD LIKE
TO. MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS I'M
BASED ON. SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION PLEASE. YEAH I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE SENATOR.
FIRST OF ALL THE REASON WHY
THESE JOBS ARE BEING EXPORTED
IS NOT BECAUSE CHINA TOOK THEM.
BUT AMERICAN BUSINESSES. THOSE
JOBS AWAY TO GET CHEAPER
WORKERS. AND OPPOSE POLICIES
THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT. TO WORK
WITH BUSINESS BY LOWERING THE
COST OF CAPITAL THE KEEPING THE
JOBS HERE. SO THIS IS AMERICAN
POLICY UNDER BOTH PARTIES THAT
TO SEND JOBS AWAY. NOT ONLY
CHINA BUT THE MEXICO AND OTHER
PLACES. THAT PUT AMERICANS OUT
OF WORK TO MAKE MORE BUCKS- FOR
THE SHAREHOLDERS SO LET'S. CALL
IT THE AY IT IS THAT'S NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO- CHINA HAS
WORKED WITH US ON THE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR DEAL- THEY- WORK
THOUGH. WITH THIS ON THE PARIS
AGREEMENT JOURNAL BOMBER AND
SHE- THEY'RE DOING THINGS. THAT
ARE MAKING MORE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND WE ARE BY A LONG
SHOT I MEAN. A MILLION A YEAR
WHICH WE HAVE TO GET TO SO
THEY'RE NOT PERFECT BUT- DON'T
DEMONISE CHINA AS THE ONLY EVIL
IN THE WORLD WE GOT A LOT OF
THE EVIL. RIGHT HERE. THEIR OWN
SELVES SO WE GOT TO CORRECT.
AND THE USE THE FUNDAMENTAL. IS
CLAIM IS DESTROYING NORVING
TELL. I'M HERE NOW I'VE NEVER
SEEN THE NGUYEN. FOR QUARTER.
IS ALMOST. DRY UP FIRST ON EVER
IN THE LIVING MEMORIES OR HERE
YOUR- IS GONNA SUCK. GREATLY
BOB YOU TAKE THE SOME PARTS
FROM CHINA WHICH IS OVER OF
THE- MERICAN. TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CHEAP LABOR
MARKET BUT BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND AMERICA HAS TO DO
SOMETHING- EUROPE- IN CHINA BUT
CHINA IS THE BIGGEST POLLUTER
SO. WE GOT TO GET THEM ON BOARD
THEY ARE ON BOARD AND WE CAN
WORK IN JOINT RESEARCH PROJECTS
AND MAKE IT BETTER YOUR IDEA
THAT THERE ARE A 100% EVIL AT
WE'RE ON A PRESENT GOOD. IS
PLAYING OUT RIGHT FALLS AND
DANGEROUS. IT'S GOING TO RESULT
IN MORE SUFFERING IF PEOPLE
LISTEN TO YOU IN YOUR DISTRICT
IN. CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. BUT TO RESPOND. YEAH
CENTER BOB FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU FOR CALLING A I GOT I SAW I
THE TO END OF A IN EDGE. IN
LOOK I'M NOT SAYING THAT
AMERICAN COMPANIES ARE PERFECT
BUT I'LL TELL YOU THE POLICIES
THAT PUSH AMERICAN COMPANIES
OUT HERE HAPPENED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND YOU WERE PART
OF IT TWO TWO TERMS AS GOVERNOR
SO IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HOW HARD IT IS TO MAKE A
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA I RUN
ONE AND I'M TAKES OF THOSE
ABOUT THE CLIMATE. MY FAMILY
HOMESTEADED HERE. AND YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S DRY. AND A LOT OF
THOSE POLICIES OF WHITES
BURNING IS BECAUSE WE- DIDN'T
DO THE RIGHT THING IN THE IN
CALIFORNIA IN OUR FORCED. BUT
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
WORLD ECONOMY AND BUSINESSES
LET'S HAVE THAT CONVERSATION IF
WE CAN PRODUCE THOSE JOBS HERE.
AND CREATE THOSE PRODUCTS WE
NEED HERE THAT'S LESS THAN THEM
DOING ITS DIRTY OVER THERE
THAT'S MY POINT THEY'VE NEVER
AGREED. OR NEVER THEY AGREE BUT
THEY DON'T DO THAT'S THE POINT
I'M I'M TRYING TO SAY AND IF
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT MEXICO.
AND IN CANADA LET'S HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AS WELL. WHERE DO
YOU THINK ALL OF OUR
AGRICULTURE IS GOING TO MEXICO
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
REGULATIONS OF THE I'VE EVER
THEIR SHIPPING THEIR FOOD IN
HERE FOR US TO EAT WITH IT'S
CONTAMINATED. SO IF WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE WORLD ECONOMY WE
HAVE TO TAKE IT ALL IN THE
CONSIDERATION. AND WE WERE
LEADING BUT WORK WERE DRIVING
CALIFORNIANS AND BUSINESSES OUT
OF THE CALIFORNIA AND AMERICANS
SO LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT THE
POLICIES THAT WE DON'T HEAR.
THAT HURT BUSINESSES TO MAKE
THEM LEAVE IF WE CAN DRIVE THE
COST OF. PRODUCING DOWN HERE WE
CAN PRODUCE IT HERE. THANK YOU
I WILL GO TO. OUR CHAIR
EMERITUS. BACK TO THE
INSTITUTE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE COULD BE
TOWARD RESEARCH WHAT ARE YOU
SEE STUDENTS AND CHINA
UNIVERSITIES STUDENTS AND- THE
LAW SCHOOLS COULD BE DOING SOME
WORK I'M- IN. BERMAN SHE SHE N.
BIDEN ARNOLD PALMER CAN HAVE
ALL THE CONVERSATIONS AT THE
WHITE WOULD- SPECIAL ENVOY
CARRYING SPECIAL ENVOYS AND HAL
I'M MORE FOCUSED ON THE SUB
NATIONAL LEVEL BECAUSE THAT'S
THE RULE TO CALIFORNIA PLACE N.
N. D. DEVELOPMENT OF THAT
DIALOGUE IN ORDER TO FURTHER
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
DIFFERENT STATES WITHIN CHINA
THE DEFENSE CITIES THE REGIONS.
THAT THEY HAVE WE SOMETIMES WE
GET CAUGHT UP WITH THE BIG
CHINA AND THE BIG UNITED STATES
WHERE I THINK THAT THE ROLE THE
ROLE FOR US AS A STEP NATIONAL
IS NOT TO LEAD IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA.
WE SPEAK OFTEN WE'RE WE'RE
LEADING BUT TO BE SUPPORTIVE SO
WHERE DO YOU SEE HOW DO YOU SEE
THE INSTITUTE WORKING AS IN THE
SUB NATIONAL ROLE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WE DO CERTAIN
THINGS WE TAKE CERTAIN ACTIONS
BUT HOW CAN WE ADVANCE THESE
ALL THESE GOALS THAT WE SHARE
AND HOW. MIGHT YOU THINK. ARE
PARTNERS IN THE CITY'S AND THE
STATES OF CHINA WE MAY INTERACT
WITH THEM THROUGH THE INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION MISTER TERRY IF
I COULD DEFER THAT QUESTION TO
THE GOVERNOR I THINK HE HAS A
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON. FANTASTIC
GOVERNOR BROWN. WE'LL GET WHAT
THE US IS THE QUESTION HERE'S
WHAT WE DOING WELL RESTATE THE
QUESTION AGAIN BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW HER THAT WELL I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT MIGHT WE
DO WE FORMALIZE THE INSTITUTE
WE HAVE WE THIRD THERE'S
FUNDING ENDED THE RELATIONSHIP
BUT THE- THE- UNIVERSITY THE
WHAT WHAT'S THE LEGISLATURE
THOSE OF US WHO CONSIDER.
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE. A YOU
KNOW WILL BE GO TO SCOTT GOING
TO DIFFERENT COME AT SYMPOSIUMS
WITH OTHER SUB NATIONALS
WORKING ON. RECYCLING OR BY SEA
LEVEL RISE HOW MIGHT WE WORK
THROUGH THE INSTITUTE OF WITH
THE INSTITUTE WHAT DO YOU
ENVISION US DOING WHAT THE
INSTITUTE TO FURTHER THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE SUB NATIONAL.
ENTITIES WITHIN CHINA. VERY
GOOD POINT BECAUSE THIS IS
ABOUT SUBNATIONAL WE HAD
INITIAL GOVERNMENT THEY'RE
DOING THEIR THING- WE'RE
WORKING FOR EXAMPLE WE PUT OUT
A VERY DETAILED REPORT. ON HOW-
CALIFORNIA IN A DIFFERENT
PROVINCES CAN GET TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY THERE A LOT OF STEPS
TO BE TAKEN IN THEIR EXAMPLES
IN CHINA- LIKE IN XINJIANG
WHERE THEY HAVE ALMOST A 100%
OF THE BUSES. ELECTRIC AND
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
OPENINGSBUT- CHINA'S GOING TO
REDUCE THEIR CALL. WE'RE
PRODUCING A STUDY NOW TO SHOW
THEM WHAT STEPS WHAT OBSTACLES
HAVE TO OVERCOME FOR THEM TO
MOVE MUCH RAP BUT MUCH MORE
QUICKLY BEGINNING WITH A COAL
THE SAME THING WITH US WHO
BRING UP EIGHTEEN BILLION.
GALLONS OF OIL AND DIESEL EVERY
YEAR WE GOT TO GET THAT DOWN
HOW DO WE DO THAT- THAT'S
COMPLICATED AND WE NEED TO MAKE
THOSE STUDIES WE CAN DO IT IN A
JOINT WAY WE'VE ALSO HAD
TRAINING- ACTIVITIES. HEARD BY
THE CLOVER BUT WE'LL GET THEM
GOING AGAIN WE'RE CONDUCTING
ACTUAL TRAINING SESSIONS WHAT
WE LEARNED IN CALIFORNIA. YOUR
RESOURCES BOARD WE CAN HELP
PEOPLE IN GUANGDONG AND OTHER
PROVINCES IN CHINA TO ADOPT
SOME OF THE- SIMILAR REGULATORY
APPROACHES SO- THERE ANY
INTERCOURSE- IS THERE ARE
ACTUAL- CHOI RESEARCHER. WERE
THEY LOOK AT SO OUR PROBLEM WE
LOOK AT OF THEIR BEST WE'RE
DOING NOW WORK IN THE LATE. WHO
ARE WELL I THINK- WE CAN HOLD A-
IS THE WITH SEND A DELEGATION-
THE COP SIX- ELEVEN WE CAN DO
BUT THAT THE MAIN POINT IS THE
PROBLEM IS SO OVERWHELMING.
THAT EVEN WORKING AT A SMALL
PART OF IT NAMELY THE
SUBNATIONAL OR- BY CITIES- WE
CAN. ADVANCE OF ALL WE CAN DO
SOME GOOD WE HAD ON THE LINE OR
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO MAYOR
GARCETTI AND THE MAYOR OF
SHANGHAI TALKING ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING SO THE THERE'S AN
OPEN. DIALOGUE HERE AND I'LL
TELL YOU ANOTHER THING AS OUR
TWO COUNTRIES THEY CLOSER TO
WAR OVER TAIWAN IT'S PRETTY
IMPORTANT THE RESULT IN SOME WE
KEEP OPEN SOME CHANNELS OF
COMMUNICATION VERY IMPORTANT TO
EXCHANGE IDEAS ON THESE CLIMATE
TOPICS. I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
GOING TO SOLVE. ALL THE
PROBLEMS BUT IT IS A POSITIVE.
SET OF STEPS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE A PART OF-
THE UC IT WAS THE CALIFORNIA-
CAN ALSO BE A PART OF AND WHICH
I'M LOOKING AT AND IF THESE ARE
SMALL. BUT POSITIVE STEPS TO A
SAFER- MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
COMPATIBLE. WORLD WHICH WE ALL
WANT TO LIVE THERE. OKAY WHAT
IT MEANT HER. THANK YOU- I
WON'T BE TO SERVE THIS I DO OF
THE NEW CAR. ABSOLUTELY
CERTAINLY CLIMATE TO SOME ON WE
WITNESSING IN MY DISTRICT THAT.
I DON'TTHINK YOU CAN HAVE-
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
UNLESS YOU HAVE COMPLIANT
PARTNERS. IN I DO NOT BELIEVE
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS
SHOWN IN ANY WAY- IN TERMS OF
THE RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
COUNTRY THAT THEY ARE COMPLIANT
AND FOLLOW THE RULES. AND WE
CAN'T SAY THAT ABOUT OUR OWN
INDUSTRIES THEY FOLLOW THE
RULES MAYBE THEY DON'T LIKE
THEM. AND THEN THEY FIND A WAY
OUT THEY GO TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
IF THEY CAN GET CHEAPER LABOR
BUT THEY WOULD STAY HERE. IF WE
DON'T DID NOT HAVE THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE THAT THEY
HAVE TO NAVIGATE A TO PRODUCE
THEIR PRODUCTS AND WE OUGHT TO
BE TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT
THAT. THAT WOULD HELP OUR I
THINK TREMENDOUSLY BUT FOR
TODAY. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
HONEST BROKERS ARE YOU. DO NOT
GET A GOOD DEAL. THANK YOU. I'M
HERE GOVERNOR AND HE SAID THERE
ARE REPUBLICAN FRIENDS ARE
BROUGHT UP THIS WHOLE QUESTION
OF HONEST BROKERS A COUPLE
TIMES IN AND- YOU KNOW NIGHT. I
MEAN I YOU'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE
TOUCHED UPON THIS A BIT. HOW DO
WE- YOU KNOW I'M NOT LIKE MY SO
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT WE CAN'T.
WITH THE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
DISCOUNT OF THE ABSOLUTE
SIGNIFICANCE OF CHINA AND THIS
CONVERSATION IN THE NEED FOR
CHINA. A FOR US TO WORK WITH
CHINA IN ADDRESSING THIS
CHALLENGE. B. TO BE GIVEN THE
CONCERNS ABOUT. ABOUT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE B. WE CAN
RELY ON THEM TO BE A OF A
PARTNER- TO BE IT'S A TO MEET
TO MEET THEIR INTERNATIONAL
OBLIGATIONS HOW HOW SHOULD THE
COMMITTEE BE THINKING ABOUT.
ABOUT THAT CHALLENGE ABOUT THIS
AT THAT ASPECT OF THIS
CHALLENGE. VERY BROAD QUESTION
FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO BE
FOCUSING ON. U. S. RELATIONSHIP
THAT'S HUGE AND THEY'RE QUITE
FRANKLY I DON'T THINK THE
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON HAVE GOT
IT RIGHT QUITE YET AND EVEN
WHAT IS RIGHT IT TAKES A LOT OF
INSIGHT AND UNDERSTANDING AND A
LOT OF THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE
THERE'S DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEW ON HOW TO HANDLE THE
CHINESE BUT I CAN TELL YOU ONE
THING. IF YOU JUST- SAY
DEMONISE THEM AND SAY THEY'RE
THE INHERENTLY EVIL WE'RE NEVER
GONNA TALK TO THEM- THAT'S NOT
HELPFUL DIALOGUE IS NOT A
REWARD- BECAUSE YOU'RE LIKE
SOMEBODY DIALOGUE IS A
NECESSITY- PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU HAVE ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIP SINCE WE HAVE AND
THE BUSINESS CLIMATE IS CHINA
HAS SHOWN IN MANY WAYS MORE
LEADERSHIP THE AMERICAN IT WAS
TRUMP THE PULLED OUT OF- THE
PARIS AGREEMENT. IS TRUMP THAT
CANCELED- SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS WAS IN THE CHINESE
NOW WE'RE GETTING BACK TO SOME
OF THAT BUT WE HAVE MANY STAGE
AND WE'RE MONEY LEGISLATORS BUT
WANT TO GO IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION SO IT'S NOT JUST
CHINA- ALL OF US ALL HUMAN
BEINGS DRIVING A HARD TIME
FINDING WAYS TO GET OFF FOSSIL
FUEL TO GET TO A PROSPEROUS-
ACADEMY. BASED ON RENEWABLE
ENERGY IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AND
THIS IS A MATTER NOT JUST FOR
POLITICIANS BUT FOR
INTELLECTUALS FOR ACADEMICS
RESEARCHERS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS ALSO A
RESPONSIBILITY OF DIPLOMATS- TO
TRY TO CREATE OPENINGS-
WHATEVER THEY MIGHT BE I THINK
WHEN THE GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNOR NEWSOM DID SPEAK WITH
THE GOVERNOR OF GUANGDONG
THAT'S A POSITIVE WHEN THE
MAYOR OF LA HE SPOKE WITH THE
MAYOR OF SHANGHAI. THAT'S GOOD
I MEAN LOOK THE WAR DRUMS ARE
BEATING AND THAT CHINA MAY WELL
TAKE BACK TAIWAN THEY THINK
THAT THERE'S AND IF WE WANT TO
DEFEND THEM WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WORLD WAR THREE SO YOU DON'T
WHAT YOU KNOW DON'T WORRY
THERE'S PLENTY. A CONFLICT WITH
CHINA I'M JUST SAYING LET'S
FOR. THOSE OF MY PATHWAYS OR
THE USUAL CLIMATE THAT THE SUB.
LEVEL WE CAN. A LOT OF STRONG.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT. DID
YOU GO HOW HELPFUL. OKAY GOOD
DISCUSSION THE DISCUSSION
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND- THE
ITEMS BEEN MOVED BY- SILVA
CASKEY I'M IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
THOUGHTS ON ABSOLUTELY I
COULDN'T POSSIBLY REPEAT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR SET UP I AGREE
TOTALLY WITH WHAT HE SAID AND I
THINK YOU KNOW. IF I COULD JUST
PERHAPS SO GIVE A QUICK
RESPONSE ON ON- THE QUESTION
RAISED BY THE BY THE OTHER
SENATOR. I THINK CHINA HAS MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS OVER THE
YEARS AND I THINK YOU KNOW A
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THEN I YOU
KNOW I DON'T THINK WEEK WEEK WE
SHOULD EXPECT. HE ADDED I THINK
THE LEVEL OF EXPECTATION AUTUMN
OUGHT TO BE REASONABLE I THINK
IF YOU COMPARE CHINA TODAY YES
IT YOU KNOW COMPARED TO. TWENTY
YEARS AGO TEN YEARS E. SO THEY
HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
IMPROVEMENT. SO I THINK IT IT
TAKES MORE THAN A YOU KNOW A
DAY OR A MONTH TO YOU KNOW
MAKE. TREMENDOUS PROGRESS SO I
THINK WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK-
YOU MAY TAKE SOME TIME IN IN IN
THIS IS A VERY SMALL STEP LIKE
THE GOVERNOR SAID I THINK IS A
VERY MODEST TO- YOU KNOW
ATTEMPT TO. BUILD THAT KIND OF
COLLABORATION SO WITHOUT I.
ENJOYED IT THE DISCUSSION AND I
A PARTICULAR GOVERNOR I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR YOUR
WISDOM. AND TO THINK ALL THE
SENATORS FOR THE DISCUSSION
ALSO SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU. I COULD
REGULATE JERRY. MUSINGS ON
INTERNATIONAL. POLITICS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ANYTIME-
SO I DO APPRECIATE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION GOVERNOR
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
ITEM FORWARD- I DO THINK THAT
TO DIE I THINK THE DISCUSSION
WAS HEALTHY TO BE HONEST- AND
WITH A LOT OF THE ISSUES RAISED
WERE IT WERE VALID THOUGH I
THINK THEY ULTIMATELY. DON'T
TAKE AWAY FROM THE ABSOLUTE
NEED AN IMPERATIVE FOR US TO
PASS A MEASURE LIKE THIS THAT-
THAT WILL THAT WILL. I PUT
CALIFORNIA'S BEST FOOT FORWARD
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT SOME.
SOME SOLUTIONS TO THESE VERY
THORNY. THORNY ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH INTERNATIONAL
COOPERATION AS TO HOW WE AS TO
HOW WE SOLVE THIS PROBLEM SO. I
WITH THAT AT THE END OF THE
MOVE BY SENATOR CASKEY.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
ALLEN HI. HI BATES WELL BATES
KNOWN DALLY. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
ICE SKINNER STERN STERN IOWA
CASKEY BY STI. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
PULL THAT OPEN FOR A COUPLE OF
OUR MEMBERS OUT ON THE BED
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATE YOU
SUMMER CHAU BAKER IMAGE SEVEN.
GREAT SO LET'S NOW GO TO THE
FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA THIS
IS ITEM H. H. ID NUMBER ONE H.
A. R. TO. A SIMMER O'DONNELL
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS NOT ABLE TO
BE HERE IN PERSON I THINK HE'S
STILL COMING UP FROM LOS
ANGELES. SO CENTER STERN WILL
BE PRESENTING CENTER STERN
COURSES ARE CHAIR OF THE
NATURISM WATER COMMITTEE. AND
IT'S GOING TO BE SPEAKING ABOUT
AN ITEM THAT IS JUST SHOCKED
THE PEOPLE OF LOS ANGELES THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES IS COME OUT
WITH. A PRETTY. SHOCKING SERIES
OF ARTICLES ABOUT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH- DDT WAS JUST WANTONLY
DUMPED OFF OF OUR COASTLINE.
IT'S ENORMOUSLY DIFFICULT ISSUE
TO REMEDIATE- AND- IN IT IT'S
KID IN POISON CONTINUES TO SEEP
OUT- IN OUR IN OUR COASTAL
WATERS AND SO I'M I'M- WE
WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT- THIS
MORNING TO. SPEND SOME TIME
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM AS
WE DISCUSS THIS. IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION SO I WANT TO TURN TO
YOU MY FRIEND COLLEAGUE CENTER
STERN. TO START US OFF. IF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'RE
TALKING BOUT DICHLORO DIPHENYL
TRICHLOROETHANE THIS IS A-
PRODUCT THAT MANY OF US THOUGHT
WAS BURIED IN HISTORY FRANKLY-
MOTIVATED A LARGE SCALE
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT
SPECIALLY IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE MONTROSE CORPORATION
BASED IN TORRANCE CALIFORNIA
WAS THE LARGEST PRODUCER OF
THIS. EMILY VERY USEFUL AND
EFFECTIVE INSECTICIDE THAT-
SINGLE HANDEDLY. WROUGHT INTO
ENDANGERMENT- MUCH OF OUR
COASTAL WILDLIFE AND EVEN WORSE
YET- HUMAN BEINGS- THE
EFFECTIVE D. D. T. IT'S A BIO
ACCUMULATING CHEMICALS SO IT
STORES UP IN FATTY TISSUE OF
ANIMALS THAT THAT ALLOWS THOSE
CONCENTRATIONS TO SIR TO
INCREASE FARTHER UP THE FOOD
CHAIN. CAUSED EGGSHELL THINNING
AND HE THINK ABOUT WHY THE BALD
EAGLE IS BEEN ON THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION- IT'S D. D. T. HUMAN
HEALTH EFFECTS- CARCINOGENIC
CARCINOGENIC ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTING BUT OTHER- STRANGE
EFFECTS FROM THIS INSECTICIDE
ON THINGS LIKE OBESITY AND
EVEN- EARLY ON STRICT OF-
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH- SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
TONS DURING THE THIRTY FOR
THIRTY TO THIRTY YEARS OF USE.
WERE APPLIED DOMESTICALLY AND
THE HALF LIFE IN THE QUALITY
CAN VITAMINS IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS MEANING THAT IT
WILL TAKE HUNDREDS OF YEARS TO
FULLY BREAKDOWN DDT. BUT WE
THOUGHT WE HAD DEALT WITH THIS
ISSUE WHEN MONTROSE SHUT DOWN
PRODUCTION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO. I WAS BANNED FOR USE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO IN FACT
PRODUCTION CONTINUED TO. TO BE
ON A FEEDING THE EXPORT SIDE-
BUT- THERE WAS A SENSE THAT
SOMETHING HAD BEEN DONE.
HOWEVER STARTING IN THE TWENTY
TENS IN. A DDT WAS PROJECTED TO
BE DISCOVERED UCSB RESEARCHERS
USING SUBMERSIBLES ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND FEET DEEP ON THE OCEAN
FLOOR BETWEEN CALIFORNIA COAST.
AND CATALINA ISLAND STARTED
DISCOVERING BARRELS THE FOUND
ABOUT SIXTY BARRELS. OVER TWO
YEAR PERIOD. AND THEY CAN'T
HUNTING. AND SIXTY IS BALLOONED
TO TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND. IN A
FIFTY SIX MILE SQUARE AREA. AND
POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS MORE HAVE YET TO BE
DISCOVERED. OF ESSENTIALLY ACID
WASTE. IN OUR AT SEA LIFE.
WE'VE SEEN IN FACT EVIDENCE
THAT MANY OF THESE BARRELS
AREN'T JUST CONTAINED AND
HOPEFULLY UNEXPOSED TO THE SEA
BUT MANY WERE AXED- TO ALLOW
FOR- THEM TO SINK- HANDED HANDS.
HAND BASS AXING OF THESE GIRLS
HAVE. BECAUSE EXPOSURE IN
DISPOSING THAT- COULD BE FELT
FOR GENERATIONS AND THIS
RESOLUTION IS REALLY HERE NOT
JUST TO SAY THAT THE COMPANY
SETTLEMENT WHICH WAS I THINK A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS-
WAS NOT ENOUGH FRANKLY WAS
SHORT SIGHTED IN LIGHT OF THE
DISPOSABLE DISPOSAL WORK- BUT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS PARTNERS
HERE TO STOP THE BLEEDING- THE
L. A. TIMES BLEW THIS STORY
WIDE OPEN. BUT NOW WE NEED
CONGRESS AND THE EPA TO TAKE
ALL MEASURES NECESSARY TO
PREVENT THE DDT DUMPING SITE
OFF THE COAST OF LA FROM
CAUSING FURTHER HARM TO OUR
PEOPLE OUR OCEANS AND OUR
WILDLIFE. SO I APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- THIS IS ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION RESOLUTION TO-
SUPPORTED BY OUR L. A. COUNTY
BARD OF SUPERVISORS IN. A
NUMBER OF OTHERS BUT THIS IS
GOING TO TAKE FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL COOPERATION TO GET THIS-
TO GET THIS BLEEDING STOP THIS
THIS IS A- DECADES IN THE
MAKING BUT- AN UGLY TRUTH HAS
BEEN DISCOVERED IN CHILE LOOSE
WITH THE HEAL THE BAY AND
MICHAEL PARMER WITH CITY OF
HAVE A LOT OF REALLY BEEN TIP
OF THE SPEAR HERE SO I THINK
THEY'RE ON THE- PHONE TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WAS RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER STERN I MEAN IT THIS IS
AN ISSUE- YOU KNOW I'VE I AM
PROUD TO REPRESENT. BOTH THE
PALACE VERDES PENINSULA ALSO
SANTA CATALINA ISLAND- THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT'S NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART- YOU KNOW YOU AND
I. GREW UP SWIMMING IN THE
SANTA MONICA BAY. HI SENATOR
AND- IT IS JUST DESPICABLE WHEN
YOU GO AND LOOK AT THE AT THE
HISTORY OF WHAT HAPPENED HERE
PEOPLE JUST. I'M JUST DUMPING
POISON DIRECTLY INTO THE OCEAN
AND I OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T KNOW
EVERYTHING THEY KNOW. NOW ABOUT
DDT BUT THEY KNEW ENOUGH TO
KNOW THIS IS A THIS IS THE
WRONG THING TO DO. AND THIS
COMPANY AT. FIRST THE ENTIRE
REGION HI I'M IN A WAYTHAT WE
WILL WE WE'RE GONNA QUITE
FRANKLY BECAUSE- IT'S COULD BE
SO DIFFICULT FOR US TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO HOW TO HOW TO
MITIGATE AND REMEDIATE- BECAUSE
OF THE LOGISTICS. ASSOCIATED
WITH AND WITH WITH FINDING
THESE BARRELS- GET MEN AND THEN
FIGURE OUT SOME SORT OF. COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER- ATTITUDE TO
REMEDIATE SO ON HOW MANY MORE
BARRELS ARE OUT HERE WHERE
EXACTLY DID THEY COME FROM WE
KNOW MOST OF THAT WE LEAST NOW
I KNOW WE KNOW BUT I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION. YOU KNOW WHERE IT
WHAT EXACTLY IS IN THE BARRELS-
WHAT TO THE CLEANUP AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS LOOK LIKE A
LOOK AT THE STATE TODAY THESE
EFFORTS SO WE'RE NOT KILL THE A
TEENS ARE ALL THESE QUESTIONS
TODAY BUT HOPEFULLY EARLY
WITNESSES WILL HELP US BRING. A
TOGETHER A ROBUST DISCUSSION.
ON AND WE LIKE TO HAVE AN AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- ON THIS
TOPIC IN THE FALL WE DO HOWEVER
KNOW THAT THAT AT LEAST.
SOMETHING LIKE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND BARRELS FILLED WITH
DDT ARE SITTING THERE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE BAG- IN FEDERAL
WATERS MOST OF THEM- SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PULL IN OUR
PARTNERS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND- YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THIS RESOLUTION WILL.
HELP US TO DO THAT TOO SO. HOW
THE HOUSE LET'S GO TO YEARLY
WITNESSES SENATOR I LET'S GO TO
SHELLEE LOOSE FROM HEAL THE BAY
COURSES. AND INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ALLY IN THE EFFORT TO.
THAT'S IT TO CLEAN UP OUR BAY
HI DON SEMOGA BANK LET'S GO TO
YOU HI DR LOOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE. THEY
SUPPORTS AJ ARE TO THE
IMPORTANT STEP IN SOLVING THIS
BT KEY PROBLEM IN OUR LOCAL
WATERS. WE'VE WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS WE
READ THE ANGER OUT REACH
PROGRAM TO PROTECT SUBSISTENCE
FISHERS WHO ARE SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE. BY
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT DDT
CONTAMINATION IN THE FISH THAT
THEY'RE FEEDING THEIR FAMILIES
SUCH AS ONE OF THE IMPACT OF
THIS TOXIC DUMPING. THE LATEST
DISCLOSURES OF THE DEEPWATER
DUMPSITE ARE DEVASTATING AS YOU
DESCRIBED AND THEY HIGHLIGHT
BASE OF PROBLEM THAT IS NOT
GOING AWAY AND CONTINUES TO
HARM PEOPLE AND OUR ENVIRONMENT
EVERY DAY. IT IS NOT BEEN
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED BY
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. OR THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES. BUT THERE
ARE SOME STEPS. THAT WE MUST
TAKE NOW AND THIS RESOLUTION IS
PART OF THAT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MUST FUND THE
SCIENTIFIC ASSESSMENTS TO FIND
THE EXTENT OF THE CONTAMINATION
AS WELL AS STUDIES OF THE
TRANSPORT AND FATE OF THE DDT
AND OTHER CHEMICALS. BECAUSE
THE DUE PROCESS FOR A LONG TIME
AND THEY DO MOVE THROUGH FOOD
CHAIN. WE MUST INCREASE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH TO REACH
MORE OF THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WHO ARE AT RISK
FROM EATING AND FEEDING TO
THEIR FAMILIES INCLUDING
PREGNANT WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
BUILD DEVELOPING IN THEIR-
METALLURGICAL SYSTEM THEY NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE FISH
WERE CONTAMINATED AND WHAT THE
RISKS ARE EATING THE FISH. WE
SHOULD INVESTIGATE THE DUMPING
PERMIT IN RECORDS TO DETERMINE
WHO ELSE WAS RESPONSIBLE WHO
PRODUCED THIS WAY AND PROFITED
FROM THE THING WE CAN SEEK
FINANCIAL COMPENSATION TO HELP
PAY FROM THE- RELIGIOUS SAID
IT'S. GONNA TAKE A LONG TIME
IT'S GOING TO BE EXPENSIVE. I
FINALLY. WE MUST ACT UP TO DUMP
SITE WHERE POSSIBLE. THE TV
SULFATE WHICH IS CLOSE THE
PROSPERITY HAS A DEDICATED
SETTLEMENT FUNDS BUT VERY
LITTLE HAS BEEN DONE TO
ACTUALLY CLEAN UP THAT NIGHT.
RIGHT NOW HE PAGE RELYING ON
NATURAL REMEDIATION OR NATURAL
BREAKDOWN IN THE ENVIRONMENT
BUT BECAUSE OF THE INADEQUATE
MONITORING. WE DON'T HAVE THE
DATA TO BEGIN TO KNOW IF THIS
IS WORKING. OR WHERE THAT DD
IS GOING AS IT BREAKS DOWN INTO
ITS- BREAKDOWN PRODUCTS WHICH
STILL HAVE TOXICITY THEMSELVES.
SO THAT'S WHY FUNDING OF
SCIENCE DETERMINES THAT THERE
AND WHERE IT STANDING UP IS SO
CRITICAL AND AJ ARE TOO IS AN
IMPORTANT. STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THIRTY DOCTORS. LET'S NOW GO TO
MY- MY FRIEND- AND- MICHAEL
PALMER'S ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER
AT THE CITY OF AVALON. ON
CATALINA ISLAND. ALLEN CENTER
CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY-
REGARDING THE PREVIOUS DDT
DUMPING AT DISPOSAL SITES OFF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST
AS BRIEFLY MENTIONED MY NAME IS
MICHAEL PARMER AND ON THE
ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF AVALON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORTER FIRST ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION TO. AVALON IS
AN ISLAND COASTAL COMMUNITY
LOCATED ON SANTA CATALINA
ISLAND APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
MILES OFF THE COAST OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A LITTLE OVER
TWO POINT EIGHT SQUARE MILES IN
SIZE AND HOME TO APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE YEAR ROUND
WITH OVER ONE MILLION VISITORS
PER YEAR THE CITY IS THE ONLY
INCORPORATED MUNICIPALITY ON
THE ISLAND OF WHICH SEVENTY SIX
MILES OF PROTECTED NATURAL
CONSERVATION LAND WE HAVE OVER
SIXTY TWO MILES A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE UNDEVELOPED
COASTLINE NINE FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS. AND FOR AREAS A SPECIAL
BIOLOGICAL SIGNIFICANCE WERE
HOME TO MORE THAN SIXTY ENDEMIC
PLANT ANIMAL AND INSECT SPECIES
FOUND NOWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD
AND MANY PROTECTED SPECIES
MARINE LIFE THE CITY ON THE
ISLAND HAVE A VIBRANT TOURIST
AND RECREATION BASED ECONOMY
THAT PLAYS A MAJOR ROLE IN
SOLVING CALIFORNIA'S HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR OCEAN
TOURIST ECONOMY OUR CITY
POPULATION CAN INCREASE BETWEEN
210025100% OF THE PEAK SUMMER
SEASON AND OUR ECONOMY AND THE
WELFARE OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE
DEPENDENT ON TOURISM. AND
ROBUST POLICIES OF BAKER BERMAN
STEWARDSHIP A PROTECTED NATURAL
RESOURCES IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR RESIDENTS AB
ONE ON THE ISLAND HAVE A STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION PLUS
BE AN INHERENT MISSION OF
PROTECTING COASTAL RESOURCES
AND UNIQUE STATE AND FEDERAL
SAFEGUARDS THAT HELP PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT FROM POLLUTION
AND PRESERVE WATER QUALITY. AS
AN ISLAND PHYSICALLY ISOLATED
OFF THE CALIFORNIA MAINLAND BY
THE PACIFIC OCEAN WATER QUALITY
IN OCEAN CONSERVATION IS
CRITICAL TO THE PHYSICAL AND
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF OUR
ECONOMY HOWEVER THE REDISCOVERY
OF DDT AND OTHER TOXIC CHEMICAL
WASTE DUMPING AT THE DISPOSAL
SITES OFF CALIFORNIA COAST IN
THE ST PETER BASS AND POSE A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO OUR
MARINE LIFE. OUR RESIDENTS AND
DESERVES HELP AND OUR FUTURE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY. WELL THE
POLITICAL LOGICAL ON HEALTH.
FROM D. AND OTHER. WAYS DUMPING
OR STILL BEING A- DECADES LAW.
CHRIS FEDERAL AND STATE IS TO
CLEAN UP THE OUTSIDE. THE
SIGNIFICAN. OF THE AMOUNT OF DD
DUMPED IN THE BASIN CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED WELL NOT AS VISIBLE
AS A SEVENTEEN MILE SUPERFUND
SITE WAS DESIGNATED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX AT ADDRESS DDT AND
PCBS REALIZE RELEASED. FROM
WHERE SEWAGE AND- TOXIC SEWAGE
EMPTIED DIRECTLY INTO THE OCEAN
THE SCALE AND SCOPE OF DDT AND
OTHER TOXIC CHEMICAL WASTE
DUMPING. OUT INTO THE SAN PEDRO
BAY ST AMOUNTS TO GROSS
CRIMINAL NEGLIGENCE AT BEST A
POTENTIALLY ONE OF THE MOST A
BORING BAR MIDDLE STRATEGIES OF
COURSE. THE CITY OF BABYLON
VALUES THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
APPLAUDS COMMITTEE FOR TAKING
ACTION TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR WORK TO SUPPORT ALL
NECESSARY MEASURES TO PREVENT
FURTHER DAMAGE PROTECT PRESERVE
OUR BUT- FORMER NATURAL
RESOURCES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. THANK
YOU. ALRIGHT ARMS GO TO I DON'T
SEE ONE IN PERSON EITHER HERE
TWENTY FORTY TWO ONE A
TESTIFIED SUPPORT- ON THE PHONE
OF THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES LIKE
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS H. A.
R. THANK YOU. TO STATE SUPPORT
FOR A DAY OR TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN PERSON MODERATORS
ANYONE NOW AND- ON THE PHONE
LINES YOU WANT TO EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE RESOLUTION-
OPPOSITION. I KNOW IT ON THE
RESERVATION THANK YOU. IF YOU
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION OVER
THE PHONES TO AJ ARE TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEM ZERO. YEAH MY
COMMANDERS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE. THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO- LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HI. YOU KNOW. I AM I
WOULD LIKE TO I KNOW OUR OUR
OUR WITNESSES ARE PREPARED TO
ANSWER SOME SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT- ABOUT THE VARIOUS ISSUES
AT PLAY AND I KNOW THE SENATORS
WELL AND HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
BONING UP ON THIS STUFF- LET ME
LET ME LET ME JUST TO ASK OUR
WITNESSES CAN YOU GIVE US A-
SENSE OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
EFFECTS THESE CHEMICALS AND HOW
LONG THEY LAST IN THE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. MAYBE ALL ONE
THIRTY SIR WE'RE SAYING IT'S A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEAR HALF LIFE
FOR HANNITY YOUR HOUSEPLANTS
COULD BE MULTIPLE HUNDREDS OF
YEARS DEPENDING ON THE TIME OF
THE DUMPING BUT DOCTOR
LOOSENESS MORE. YEAH COULD
COULD YOU RIGHT SO IT'S A
DOCTOR WAS IF YOU COULD TALK
ABOUT IT JUST A BIT MORE UNITY
SPOKE TO ABOUT THIS BUT WHAT
WHAT ARE THE- JUST AT THE TOP
LINES OF THE FACTS WE SHOULD BE
MOST CONCERNED ABOUT AND- IN A
AND THEN THE OTHER THING IS.
WHAT WHAT DO WE NOT KNOW I MEAN
WHAT WHAT DO YOU WHAT WHAT
WORRIES YOU. AS TO AS TO AS TO
AS TO QUESTIONS THAT STILL NEED
TO BE ANSWERED. WITH REGARDS TO
THE G. YES. THANK YOU- WELL THE
TOP LINE AFFECTS OUR BED
SENATORS YOU'RE MENTIONED
CANCER AND ENDOCRINE OR
REPRODUCTIVE EFFECTS AND WE
KNOW THAT THE CANCER CAUSING
CHEMICALS NOT ONLY IN THE LAB
WORK THROUGH DIRECT EXPOSURE
BUT THROUGH THE FOOD CHAIN AND
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF THE
EPIDEMIC OF CANCER THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN FELINES WHICH HAS
BEEN LINKED CONCLUSIVELY TO THE
DDT CYLINDER MAMMALS JUST LIKE
US THEY'RE EATING FISH AND IT'S
CONCENTRATING THROUGH THE FOOD
CHAIN. AND INTO THEIR TISSUES
AND CAUSING CANCER WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE ALSO EATING FISH
WERE SOME OF THE TOP PREDATORS
IN THE OCEAN AND WE KNOW THAT
FISH THAT PEOPLE CONSUME
LOCALLY HAVE HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF DDT SO THAT'S
MY NUMBER ONE CONCERN IF WOMEN
WHO ARE PREGNANT OR CHILDREN
WHO ARE STILL DEVELOPING BRAINS
AND NERVOUS SYSTEM- CONCEALMENT
FISH IT CAN HAVE A VERY VERY
AREA- HARM TO THEM CAN CAUSE
VERY SERIOUS HARM TO THEM.
ANOTHER AFFECT THAT IS ONLY
BECOMING CLEAR OVER TIME IS THE
LONG TERM GENERATIONAL IMPACT
AND THAT'S REALLY SCARY TO ME
AND I THINK TO EVERYONE BECAUSE
WE NOW KNOW THAT CHILDREN AND
GRAND CHILDREN OF WOMEN WHO
WERE DIRECTLY EXPOSED TO DDT IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES CHAU
REPRODUCTIVE IMPACTS TODAY THAT
THE EARLY ONSET OF MENSTRUATION
THE CHANGES IN MENSTRUAL
PERIODS AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
FEMALE REPRODUCTIVE CYCLE. AND
ALSO THE BAY CITY AND OTHER
HORMONE RELATED ILLNESSES ARE
PRESENT IN A GRAND CHILDREN OF
WOMEN WHO ARE EXPOSED EACH IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES SO WE ARE
WE JUST FIND OUT OVER TIME JUST
HOW BAD HOW PERVASIVE. NEED
CHEMICAL ARE AND THOSE THAT IT
EVEN HARDER TO DO IN WILDLIFE
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN DOLPHINS
AND WHALES WE DON'T KNOW THEY
MARRIED. BE SHOWING THE SAME.
IMPACT SO FIRST PART OF YOUR
YEAH I. THE NEXT PART. WELL THE
QUESTION BILL WANNA GO ON TO ON
LITTLE SUMMARY MEDIATION- AND
SO I KNOW THIS ISN'T A NEW
PROBLEM I MEAN THE SO THE
PALACE VERDES COASTAL SHELF. I
HAD D. V. T. WASTE. WITH THE
DISCHARGE OFFSHORE- THAT'S BEEN
A SUPERFUND SITE SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE I BELIEVE. I'M SO.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THERE AND HOW HOW THE
EFFORTS THERE MIGHT INFORM A
RESPONSE OF THE DUMPSITES
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT. THE
EFFORTS THERE IT MORE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WE KEEP HEARING IS
THAT THIS IS JUST AN IMMENSELY
DIFFICULT PROBLEM TO SOLVE-
WHAT WHAT CAN WE LEARN FROM THE
EXISTING SUPER FIND ACTIVITIES
HAPPENING OFF THE COAST. WELL I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT APPROACH
SENATOR BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
DIFFICULT PROBLEM AND WE FEEL
LIKE TRYING THEIR HANDS IN THE
AIR. BUT YOU'RE RIGHT THAT'S
NOT A NEW PROBLEM WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS OFF THE PULSE RATIO
BUT WE DO HAVE- ASSIGNED THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION SOME
OF IT THANKS THANKS IT'S ONLY
BEEN SPENT ON THE INSTITUTIONAL
CONTROLS AS FAR AS I KNOW WHICH
IS- PREVENTING THE SALE OF
LOCAL FISHING FISH MARKET. AND
REACHING OUT TO LIKE WE HAVE
PEOPLE WALKING ON PEERS TALKING
TO. ANGLERS ABOUT THE DANGER OF
BEING THIS ISSUE THEIR FAMILIES
WHAT WE NEED TO DO BETTER IS
ACTUALLY MONITOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THIS CHEMICAL IN
THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT IN THE
SENTIMENT IN THE WATER. IN THE
ANIMALS IN THE OCEAN FORGET
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK
WE CAN LEARN FROM- THE LACK
BEEN. LESS SUCCESSFUL WORK ON
THE TV SHOW SO FAR- ALSO ON THE
TV SHOW WE HAVE HAD A PILOT
PROJECT. WHEN WE TRIED TO DO
CAPPING WHICH MEANS YOU PUT AN
INNER CAP THAT SENTIMENT ON TOP
OF THE CONTAMINATED SEDIMENT TO
PREVENT THE CONTAMINATED
SEDIMENT FROM ESCAPING INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT WAS SUSPENDED
THAT CAPPING PROJECT- IN PART
BECAUSE- THE EPA. MONITORING
WITH MACHINES JUST IT BREAK
DOWN IN THE IN BY. I'M BORED.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN. UP ANOTHER.
COLOR TO KNOW. IF THAT'S
WORKING AND WHERE THAT DDT IS
GOING BECAUSE WHEN IT BREAKS
DOWN IT DOESN'T JUST GO RIGHT
FROM DDT. TO HARMLESS CHEMICALS
LIKE CARBON AND NITROGEN THAT
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH SEVERAL
STAGES OF. OTHER TOXIC
BREAKDOWN PRODUCTS OF THE DTE
LIKE BEEF FOR EXAMPLE BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND MUCH
BETTER WHERE IT'S GOING IT'S NO
LONGER IN THE SENTIMENT IN THE
SAME LOCATION AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO. AND
THAT. SCIENTISTS AT. THE UC
SANTA BARBARA AND SCRIPT. AND
NOW I HAVE ALREADY STARTED TO
DO AND THAT'S WHY THE FEDERAL
FUNDING WILL BE SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE CAN SEE. WHAT IS OUT
THERE HOW MUCH WHERE IT IS THAT
HE SAID WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE.
FULL EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM- AND
WHERE IT'S GOING THE FOR CHAIN.
I'M DOCTOR WAS EITHER BEING
SHORT OF PRESSURING THE FADS
WHICH OF COURSE IS SEEMS TO BE
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE CAN DO ON THIS TOPIC.
I'M WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE WHAT
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE STATE'S
ROLE IN ALL THIS LIKE WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO THOSE OF
US. IN THE STATE GOVERNMENT WHO
WERE. REALLY DISTRESSED AND
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS THIS
CHALLENGE. WHAT WHAT IT WHAT IS
YOUR ADVICE FOR ASSISTANCE AS A
STEP TO ANNOTATE. I THINK WE
SHOULD COMMIT SOME SMALLER
AMOUNT OF STATE FUNDING TO HELP
MAKE SURE THIS GETS STARTED.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT THE
STATE- CAN LOOK INTO THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND FIGURE OUT
IF THERE IS FURTHER
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT CAN BE-
SURFACE SO THAT WE CAN. GET THE
PROPER AMOUNT OF FUNDING AS YOU
SAID IT WASN'T ENOUGH THE FIRST
TIME AROUND THE MAYBE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE DUMPING
THIS TIME. WE HAVE RECORDS AND
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE I THINK
THE STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE. COULD REALLY PURSUE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE DUMPING
ITSELF. I ALSO HOPE THAT THE
STATE WILL PUT IN PLACE ALONG
WITH THE FEDS. SOME SORT OF
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE BECAUSE
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT WHEN WE
HAVE A DUMP SITE LIKE THIS THAT.
ENGINE SO MANY STATE AGENCIES
SO MANY DIFFERENT SCIENTISTS
AND EXPERTS AND AFFECTS SO MANY
DIFFERENT. PEOPLE FROM THE
SUBSISTENCE FISHERS TO THE
PEOPLE ON CATALINA ISLAND. TWO
OTHER TOURISM AND RECREATION
AND DIVE TYPE OPERATIONS THE
VERY HARD TO KEEP EVERYONE
INFORMED AND IT'S VERY HARD. TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
SCIENTISTS INVOLVED ARE. YOU
SPEAKING TO EACH OTHER AND
GETTING THE RIGHT INFORMATION
TO THE PUBLIC SO THAT WE CAN
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THE IMPACTS
OF PUBLIC OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
THAT INCLUDED FINANCES AS WELL
AS ADVOCATE THAT YOU FEEL THE
BANK I THINK COULD HEP. KEEP
THIS EFFORT MOVING FORWARD AND
MAINTAIN THE TRANSPARENCY THAT
WE ALL NEED IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PEOPLE. YEAH I MEAN YOU KNOW
WE'RE HAVING A SIDE BAR HERE
WAS CENTER CASKEY ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IS
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THIS IS
FEDERAL WATERS- YEAH ALL RIGHT.
QUESTIONS FROM OTHER MEMBERS
ANY UNKNOWN UNKNOWNS MISTER
CHAIR MANY UNKNOWNS UNKNOWNS
AND- YEAH THAT'S RIGHT. TO
QUOTE OUR FRIEND DONALD
RUMSFELD YES- VERY DISTRESSING
VERY DISTRESSING OKAY- AND
OTHER QUESTIONS VOTES IN THE
COMMITTEE. YES SENATORS OZZY
REPRESENTS THE AREA AS WELL YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT TO
THANK MY- COLLEAGUE OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES CHAIR HERE IN THE
SENATE AS WELL AS MY HOMETOWN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF PATRICK
O'DONNELL FOR BRING IN THIS
SORT OF GOT LOTS OF FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO LIVE. IN THE AREA
BUT OF COURSE REPRESENTING LONG
BEACH- AND KNOWING HOW DIRE
THIS IS FOR US- IT REMINDS ME
UNFORTUNATELY OF LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
WITH EXIDE- IN VERNON AND SO
ANYWAY THAT I CAN BE HELPFUL I
WOULD LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL- INTO LIFT UP THESE THESE
ISSUES YOU KNOW AT THE STATE
LEVEL WOULD BE. WOULD BE GREAT
BUT EAH THERE ARE A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS AND I DON'T HAVE THE
FIT SUFFICIENT QUESTIONS FOR
THESE UNKNOWNS BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH THAT IS JUST OUT THERE
SO- IT'S FRUSTRATING BUT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
THE PROJECT THIS THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO BE OUT OF THIS CAR OUT
THERE TO- OKAY. WELL IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GONZALEZ AND IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER. I
WOULD I WOULD ADD ON IS I DON'T
KNOW IF I'M A CO AUTHOR AT THIS
POINT EVEN THOUGH I'M A
PRESENTER BUT LOVE TO BE ADDED
ON AS WELL. AND A LOOK FORWARD
TO THIS COMMITTEE DIGGING IN.
DEEPER TO THIS UNFOLDING SLOW
MOVING TRAGEDY BEFORE OUR EYES
THE FORTUNE WE HAVE TO BE HERE
BUT- APPRECIATE CHU
HIGHLIGHTING AND LET'S TAKE
SOME ACTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER. ALL RIGHT I'VE GOT
SOME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER ONE AJ ARE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN HI. AND
I'D BATES. BATES AYE DOLLY.
DOLLY I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER. STERN STERN AYE WHAT
COUNTY. YEAH OKAY A SUIT SO-
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
OTHER FOLKS TO ADD ON WIRELESS
THE CALLS IF WE DO GET A CENTER
SKINNER. MMHM IF THERE. OKAY
WITH THE PROBLEM HOW GREAT OKAY
SO IF WE DIDN'T ENCOURAGE
CENTERS GONNA COME DOWN
DIRECTLY THE BUDGET VOTES ARE
DONE. YEAH I'M PUTS DO A ROUND
OF LIFTING OF CALLS FOR OUR
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE SO LET'S
LET THE CALL AND ITEM TO THE ZG
R. FOR CRISTINA GARCIA IS BILL
ON THE RATIFIED THE BASEL
CONVENTION. THE RESOLUTION.
THAT COULD SO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
THE VOTERS TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI AND THE VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING. BATES DALLY.
DALLY NOT VOTING. SKINNER STERN
HI STERN HI WHY CASKEY. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
SUMMER CASKEY IN SKINNER TO ADD
ON THIS DO ITEM THREE THIS IS A
B. THIRTY NINE I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THIS ONE IS ACTUALLY
GOING STRAIGHT TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE TO A RUNNY C.
NOW SAYS GOING TO. NATURAL
RESOURCES SO IT'S A DEEP PASS
TO NATURAL TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AB
THIRTY NINE CONSULT PLEASE
COLOR. THIS HAS THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D THE VICE YOU'RE
VOTING NO THE VOTE IS FOUR TO
ONE. DALLI DALLI NO SKINNER.
OKAY THREE TO HOLD THAT OPEN
FOR CENTER SKINNER- ITEM FOR
THE B. THROUGH FOR A BILL CORKS
BILL. FIVE THIS CONCERT WAS
KALRA. I AM NUMBER FOUR AB.
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING EITHER BY SERVING AYE
DALLI. DALLI NO SKINNER. STERN
HI STERN I Y. CASKEY OKAY LET'S
GO TO THE CONSECUTIVE VICE
CHAIRS MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- SO WE'LL LOOK LET'S
HAVE A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE
BATES BATES HI DALLY DALLY I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
STERN HI STERN AYE Y. CAO SKI.
OKAY THIRTY MEMBERS- WE'RE
GOING AWAY FOR CENTER SKINNER
WITH CASSIE TO COME BACK. TEN
OUT ON THEIR VOTES. COME ON
WELL YEAH WITH SKINNER COME ON
DOWN. LET'S MAKE A DEAL MANY
YEARS AGO YEAH.
OKAY. WITH THIS
CURRENT THAT SENATOR DEFINITELY
MUSTAPHA OKAY.
ALL OF. CHINA
OKAY ARE SWITCHES OVER THE
RULES YOU CAN YOU CAN TAKE ON
THE WILL ITEM ITEM NUMBER ONE
AJ ARE TOO THIS IS O'DONNELL'S
RESOLUTION ON CATALINA ISLAND
AND DTT. CONSULTAS COLOR- THE
MOTION IS- DO PASSPORT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN HIGH
VICE REPORTING I'D VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO BY CASKEY HI. I THAT'S AT
SIX TWO ZERO SKINNER IS THINNER
OKAY SO IT'S WAY ON THAT WILL
THAT. OPEN FOR. HELLO OKAY
SHOULD CONSIDER ON A ARE TOO.
SKINNER I FIVE. SKINNER OKAY
BECAUSE THEY'RE ON AT SEVEN
ZERO- LET'S COULD I TO AG ARE
FOR CRISTINA GARCIA IS BILL AND
READ THE CAN. MOTION IS A KNOW
YOUR RIGHTS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN NG I
ADVISED HER NOT VOTING. VOTE IS
THREE ZERO SKINNER. SKINNER
IOWA CASKEY BY ASKI I'D BUT
FORTY ZERO- FIVE. FIVE ZERO
RIGHT FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT. OKAY NEXT WE GO TO AD
CHAO'S AB THIRTY NINE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE COVERAGE
CHINA CLIMATE INSTITUTE. PUBLIC
COLLAROS GOING TO PROBES.
GARNER PROBST OUR VICE CHAIR
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE AYE SURE
NOT VOTING ADVISED HER VOTING
NO LOTUS FORTY ONE SKINNER.
INNER I. OKAY THAT'S FIVE TWO
ONE NIGHT IS OUT WE'RE GONNA
CLOSER ON THAT AB THREE OH FOUR
QUIRKS BILL AND- CONSULTAS
CORAL. AND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE Y. CAO
SKIING BY. OKAY WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THAT ONE. AND IT JUST
BRINGS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSULT PLEASE COLOR OF SKINNER
HI THERE I Y. CASKEY FIVE. ALL
RIGHT BECAUSE THE ROLE IN THAT
I WOULD APPRECIATE EVERYBODY
SORRY I KNOW OF SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WE DOUBLE BOOKED IT
PROCEEDS YOU CAN APPEAR FOR THE
VOTES AND- WITH THAT WE WILL.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY WE'LL WE'LL
ADJOURN THIS HEARING AND WE'LL
BE BACK WITH THE WITH A- LONGER
AND MORE CONTROVERSIAL HEARING.
NEXT NEXT TIME AROUND THANK YOU
AND THANKS AGAIN TO OUR STAFF
IN A BOTH- THE COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE. FOR HELPING TO
FACILITATE.